[Musica]
bene
forse campo sono sulla schiena ma
vediamo
allora mi sento molto fortunata che
potevo crescere in mezzo alla natura
molto molto libera non c'era mai nessuno
che mi diceva non fare questo non fare
quell'altro non sporcarti non farti male
o non andare nel bosco perché lì c'è
qualcosa di pericoloso
quindi potevo tutto l'anno godermi di
questa bellezza
della natura perché non c'era una
stagione che preferivo era sempre sempre
qualcosa da vedere fuori
la natura mi coccolava con le sue
meraviglie con i profumi con i suoni con
quello che vedevo e quello che toccavo
chi sa i bambini di oggi quelli super
tecnologici se hanno la stessa fortuna
di me di crescere in un ambiente così
meraviglioso
la spensieratezza
forse è una delle cose più importanti
che i genitori possano
regalare ai loro figli e io sono
convinta che solo la crescita nella
natura può far crescere veramente bene
un bambino e per questo io mi ricordo
molto bene quando questa mia libertà e
questa mia spensieratezza da un giorno
all'altro ha preso un pugno in faccia
avevo 12 anni e il mio corpo mi faceva
vedere dei forti limiti per day
grossi dolori che avevo nella schiena e
nelle ginocchia ed allora in poi questi
dolori erano i miei compagni di vita ma
io non pensavo mai a volare perché non
esisteva che la tamara è debole ma
non avevo mai pausa di questo dolore ea
volte era veramente difficile
vivevo dei momenti molto di gioia però
allo stesso momento poi mi buttava
dentro in depressioni fortissimi però
non pensavo mai a rallentare o a darwin
stoppa allenamenti duri e anche gare
nonostante che mentre lo facevo a volte
piangevo
ma per me esisteva solo la prestazione
come vedete la maggior parte della mia
vita ero andata
e forse questo era poco il mio modo per
mascherare un po le mie debolezze non
non le volevo vedere ormai faceva parte
di me sembrava quasi che dovevo punire
il mio corpo perché mi faceva sempre
così tanto male
eh sì e poi nonostante tutto questo male
ma andavo sempre oltre oltre oltre non
potevo fermarmi e così ho cominciato a
fare le gare di scialpinismo senza saper
sciare che alla fine mi ha comunque
portato a vincere un mondiale under 23 e
poi ho cominciato anche gli 8.000
senza essere stato prima sopra i 4.000
e qui si vede una bellissima fanciulla
come vedete
si capisce veramente che gli 8 mila
erano il mio sogno facevo tutto e di più
per andare là e così ero molto felice
che nel 2014 avevo la fortuna di poter
andare al k2
questo è una foto del campo base e
vedete che non stavo molto bene ero
spinta da un dolore molto strano che era
la pena d'amore e oltre quello avevo
altri dolori come vedete qua mi sono
gonfiate come un pallone forse a causa
di un'allergia del sole non si sa però
gonfia dappertutto allergia che mi
graffiava fino ai sanguinare avevo anche
una tendinite al tendine d'achille però
sempre avanti sempre avanti non mollavo
mai
e così dopo due mesi di fatica di
sacrificio di dolori eccetera sono
comunque è riuscita ad andare in cima al
k2 lì dove avevo la fortuna di essere
tra le poche donne che sono riuscite a
farlo senza ossigeno e tra quelle anche
la più giovane
non bastava la già venti giorni dopo
volevo fare ho fatto con la mia compagna
di gara una gara di corsa la transalp
island dove abbiamo attraversato le alpi
da nota su facendo più di
250.000 sì
250 km he più di 16mila metri di
dislivello
abbiamo vinto anche questa però poi non
vi dico come commessa
mi hanno ricoverata nell'ospedale dieci
giorni di ossigeno causa polmonite
ma neanche dopo tutto questo mi bastava
ancora e dovevo ancora andare oltre e
così mi sono secondo me messa nel apice
della sofferenza che sono gli otto
milano inverno dove sei tu nel tuo
piccolo team in solitudine nel freddo e
spesso guardia anche negli occhi della
morte
sì
le spedizioni di inverno sono veramente
ancora un passo di più e io non volevo
mai essere vista come
come alpinista al femminile non non
volevo mai sentirmi dire la donna perché
per me non aveva importanza e lo so è
molto voluto però io non ero mai o non
potevo mai essere orgoglioso di essere
una donna io mi
definivo attraverso la prestazione e non
il genere
e così mi mancava ogni forma di
equilibrio e tutto quello che alla fine
magari mi poteva regalare ancora
qualcosa di equilibrio o di qualcosa di
simile l'ho semplicemente eliminato l'ho
messo in un cassetto e l'ho nascosto nel
profondo di me stessa e così tutto
quello che io naturalmente libera che
poteva regalarmi un po di questa libertà
mi sono proprio uccisa
seguendo solo questa unica
via e non c'era altro
dovevo imparare ancora tantissimo e
anche questa spedizione che abbiamo
fatto insieme a simone moro d'inverno
2019 2020 mi ha insegnato tantissimo
sono arrivato a casa con una mano che
non aveva più sensibilità
è un molto delusa ma allo stesso momento
dovevo anche essere felice di essere
ancora in vita perché poteva essere
molto peggio potevo anche non ritornare
più
poi sono andata dal mio amico fabiano un
guru quello che mi mette sempre un po a
posto vado lì da lui e mi e aveva lì una
sua amica lei altrettanto speciale
lui mi tratta sul suo lettino e la sua
amica semplicemente mi guarda e mi dice
sei
un uomo
sei completamente un uomo
e io ho detto ok
e dopo un po che mi guardava ancora mi
diceva e se tu non riesci ad apprezzare
la tua energia femminile ti do ancora un
anno di vita
io sono andata a casa
abbattuta e ho pensato adesso devo
riflettere un po e in effetti in questa
spedizione
se lo analizzavo bene ero come una
macchina come un robot che gravava solo
i 500 metri di dislivello che siamo
riusciti a fare il 18 giorni e che
secondo me dovevano essere molti di più
però perché lo vedete la
era un labirinto infinito senza limiti e
abbiamo veramente fatto fatica
dopo questo sono sia nato a casa e mi è
arrivata la seconda sberla ma questa
sberla ci è arrivata a tutti noi era il
lock ton stoppa tutto e mi sono chiesta
ma cosa mai mi ha fatto stare ferma e
adesso cosa faccio come come mi comporto
mi faccio abbattere o prova a vedere il
bicchiere bicchiere mezzo pieno
quando si trattava di una sfida fisica
non avevo mai problemi volevo e potevo
affrontare qualsiasi cosa ma se si
trattava di qualcosa di mentale avevo
sempre una super scusa che è
io sono così e quindi mi chiedevo dove
posso cominciare
forse era ora
di riccone torni un po con questa natura
genuina
pura che già da bambina mi faceva stare
così bene così felice così solare e
sorridente e anche spensierati
spensierata
e forse la prossima l'altra cosa era di
fare qualcosa per le altre persone e non
guardare solo a me e così avevo un pò
trovato la soluzione allora ho fatto
meditazione nel bosco attorno a casa e
ho fatto le
lezioni on line i miei social con la mia
community e li devo dire che la
tecnologia non era neanche così male
dopo tutto questo una volta che eravamo
liberi
ho detto ok adesso faccio un viaggio col
mio camper mi godo la mia libertà e sono
partita per fare la cima più alta di
ogni regione d'italia
ma non solo quello volevo anche
incontrare tutta questa bella gente che
si è allenata con me durante il lock tam
e potete immaginare come era
incredibilmente bello di scoprire
l'altoatesina tutta l'italia ed era
altrettanto bello di capire che anche
facendo semplicemente 1000 metri di
dislivello
anche se non è un
granché una grande prestazione ma a me
dava una gioia incredibile
82 giorni ero in giro
a camminare a scalare a pedalare a
volare col parapendio pop come le
avrebbe fatto la tamarra da bambina
curiosa
esploratrice è molto molto
felice di ogni imprevedibile che
capitava lo vedevo come il regalo più
bello
e forse anche per quello un semplice
brindisi con la gente
anziana di un posto spopolato sotto ai
piedi del monte gorzano
2.458 metri che non è una grande
montagna ma mi ha fatto emozionare mi
hanno aspettato giu io sono venuta giù
col parapendio e mi mi hanno accolto
tutti quanti insieme e mi hanno
festeggiato
vengo forse per la prima volta nella mia
vita dopo il mio essere bambina ero
capace di accettare questo amore materno
che la natura mi dava
e questo era possibile perché io ero di
nuovo capace di aprirmi verso di lei
aman domi e facendo le cose con amore
senza pensare a obiettivi a record o a
prestazione
se ci vogliamo fare qualcosa di buono e
di prezioso allora forse ci dobbiamo
regalare di vivere un po nella natura e
di respirare insieme a lei perché dalla
natura deriviamo e un giorno purtroppo
dobbiamo tutti quanti ritornare di nuovo
da lei
quindi la natura per me non è
semplicemente un posto da visitare
occasionalmente un parco giochi come io
lo pensavo che fosse per tanti anni ma
la natura e proprio casa nostra
a braccio e amore e siamo tutti noi
grazie mille
[Applauso]